welcome mr. marvel training gentlemen my
name is Thomas Coyne and over the next
24 hours I'm going to be training you
for and if you don't perform you will
die why are we here so History Channel's
new show alone challenged us to try and
survive in the woods with no outside
help we're gonna be by ourselves no I
always tell people is you don't fail
until you quit or gone and dying is just
the body's quitting you can think about
it we could experience an apocalyptic
event at any point who's the cutest
being I think Keith is gonna be smarter
about this I got a shoe but it's got a
hole in it so I see you have a cook
tonight we're not gonna need things like
that lacy that backpack tune my Boy
Scout Troop would always bring bacon
that's the boy Scout's motto be prepared
that's cool here I'll be your Boy Scout
Handbook and not prepared for this at
all I'm concerned about finding food I'm
excited to kill something maybe I'll be
good at whittling what I'm most worried
about is the other tribe guys because I
never know what's gonna happen when
you're all out
first things first is fire there's many
ways to make fires this is by far the
most difficult in the freshen fire now I
want this ass I'm gonna save this some
good ass what I'm gonna do the number
one killer and loading a survival is
exposing being too hot or too cold for
too long so you're making a bed not for
comfort but so that the ground doesn't
freeze you to death first we want to
size this I want it hip high is that
foremost point where you stick the head
of a prized animal to like ward off
other survivors other survivors
you aren't like hell yeah kind of bad
yeah let's let's do it sticks on sticks
is this where we go like a cooking show
and it's just like ding and now it's bad
that's looking pretty good guys
from there we'll do water purification
and locations you already in
Cryptosporidium are the two most common
illnesses in water in the wilderness man
Giardia right this is operated really
simply I would like you're peeing that's
fun what do I do when I have to poop
yeah that's the thing right start to
build up monkey but get that monkey but
get that monkey but we have pools like
this that's the best place to find fish
in these mountain rivers hey you know
not every stream has fish these greens
aren't necessarily high in calorie but
they're high in nutrients this tastes
like a plant
ants are always edible great protein
real tasty it's still a lively we did
yeah
crawling around your mouth instantly
when I cross them three two one okay so
I guess this is it
all right guys time for the real thing
so my prediction is that Keith and zag
will die why are we doing this and then
and I might have to harvest their bodies
for food
I really thought keep I think is tastier
she's gonna kill us
so I have some packs here for you
basically everything you need and maybe
even some things you don't I'll give you
guys all this and I just want you guys
now tan to your pocket I was planning on
calling my wife that's cool okay now
this is everything this is that yeah how
many cookies do you have it so no we're
gonna give you each a little camera to
film your experiences okay yay so we
don't really want you guys helping each
other out and giving each other any
moral support so you know what it's like
to feel alone I'll be by in the morning
to pick you or your body out just
remember nature hates you and wants you
dead three two one go yeah okay
you that you Eugene I have a husband I
don't died care I'll see you or your
body in the morning ok bye Keith my crew
this is dumb
do I have to go this way yeah ok this is
stupid
and here we go welcome to paradise
oh we're gonna die found a nice spot
over here I think I'm gonna nail this I
want to do this is the worst I could
definitely live here for a long time I
don't know how I got here
fire starters don't need those I got a
rope ething I don't think they gave me
rope how am I gonna make anything clear
this somebody's already done my work
what idiot is gonna build a whole new
teepee thing when you already found one
I'm just the best survivalist I guess I
could use my shoelaces rope imagine if
you work velcro today I'll be dead I got
one more thing in here puppy stickers
okay good there cats on there - kazoos
for days if you need to save me I'll be
surrounded by festive colors I'll call
her
Stacey the elephant what do you think we
should do first t-rex the fire I know I
should probably be working on a fire
first
but I'm gonna look at these stickers and
I'm gonna go take a poop be prepared
thank oh oh I'm ready it's just like
slicing up that is the shelter Stacey
nice knowing you you're gonna go hunting
go and I'm gonna go poop goodbye
[Music]
oh yeah cute trees I forgot to get
anything to wipe with I wish my wife
were here no that is really rough that
is bad for but which I get this bed zone
I might switch gears and go to the fire
got it or got hit I have no idea if I'm
doing this not right rocket even in
nature I'm taking off my clothes when
it's wet inside I was like a wet wipe
got great man time to wipe my butt with
the plants make great fear then kill
fish with Spears leaves not a good way
to wipe your butt phishing attempt one
fail cuz there was not many fish it's
not too hard to get water and so over
this but I just want to get it shout out
on my strengths pretty much pretty
successful poop and quite a beautiful
place to do it actually no one told me
how boring this was gonna be
[Music]
so fishing with the bus can I still
remain a shelter yeah got my supercool
campground this is where I'm gonna make
a home maybe I'll give it another go
after I get some water first thing first
don't want bears to attack me so I'm
just gonna make a pee perimeter the only
victory so far is squeezing water into
my mouth I've accomplished nothing time
to build a shelter there's a dam in the
river and I have just a bunch of sticks
on it all the stuff they told us to make
a bed out of it down by the river and
I'm like nowhere near a river Ned's just
probably running around screaming what's
up at plants Oh what you want what you
seen at this point has to strip down and
try to become nature come play a game of
can I eat you
god I just hope Zach's not dead yeah
it's pretty uncomfortable it's also some
just a bandage sheet metal I miss my
wife dinosaur I know
start cat and puffy stickers worthless
right wrong I used them as tape I'm
crushing this a building a junkyard
right in front of everybody Zack did you
throw the badass shelter hell yeah you
did
you want a little tasty treat up some
water hell yeah you do today I'm free
this is that's great nature's awesome
that is nasty
Oh in exact saves a day make sure you
cut your hand immediately on the plant
oh I thought it was mint I was wrong and
I got a boo-boo on my finger I thought
I'd be spending my dinner this is
everything that humans were designed to
do but it's actually really difficult
but you got to keep your chin up because
I put the camera up there looks like the
sun's about to go down fire time is so
much harder than it looks on TV so close
I tried making this wooden cran but I
lost the rope so okay I have this flint
when you touch it it makes a spark
that's been cool already
oh my god take this cube and you chop it
up and it looks like this little pile of
cocaine the cube does seem to be on fire
on the package it's not working okay
what I do come on baby light for me
might be an important time to mention
I've never used flint before I don't
know what sue happens
[Music]
you got this
Oh oh that's a fire yes yes fire the
fire Cuba's come through I built that
fire this is the greatest day of my life
no matter what life will prevail with
the fire pure no one will stop me with
my tiny cube of potential fire night I
will be strong I will not give up the
fight that feels amazing those are those
satisfying things I've ever done I don't
know I'm really proud of myself I'd say
I'm this video survivor there is
everything would be so much better if I
just had the other guys help my friends
aren't dead I just woke up three chords
and this coffee so much I just want to
go home
I don't quite know proper way to
distinguish the fire it was like I gotta
do this good if I had to do this for
another day I would lose my how many
kazoos can you play it once I found this
beetle it's the thing I absolutely
didn't want to eat yesterday I found a
gun time to try and find the other
people and yet I found a gun let's go
back let's go back together we are one
with nicotine don't ever let broke what
his name is Keith oh that's right here
right now right here right here
cheer with the Knicks are you sure this
is the way back which means if we're
coming back we should need to go this
direction so tell me how do you think it
went
[Music]
first you have dumb luck that's Kate the
point is I'll take dumb luck over skill
any day
now the opposite end of that spectrum
critical thinking it's key to this how
would keep him died what I would say is
hypothermia Oh seeking training
using it that's exceptional that's
exactly what I want to see yeah an
emotional intensity can be great out
here however once against the to the
negative range it can be in the end what
takes you out the UPS is giving it all
you got all the time until you succeed
however when you're out here alone the
acceptability of risks changes if you
would have slipped and hit your head
that risk-taking might be the end of you
stab your mother was in the face of a
motor canal so once you find yourself
lost in the woods the best thing you
should do is stop think observe plan and
prioritize who hygiene is kind of a big
deal if you're gonna be there awhile
how would I've got urine and fecal
matter build up around the camp can lead
to disease things like that literally
sleeping in a ring of my own piss is not
the best idea what we learned here today
was out to survive when it comes down to
it if there was an apocalypse and there
were a zombies it's not gonna be maybe
if there was on these pack cookies if
nothing else packed cookies I guess Ned
was right the Boy Scout motto of being
prepared is probably the best thing you
can do people there get the [ __ ] away
from me yet yeah a lot harder than they
make it out to seem in Boy Scouts if
your life depends on it
you really
have your technique down Salah I have
total newfound respect for survivalist I
think what they do is unbelievable and
the skills that they have are skills
that probably everyone to try and
so coin you would get coffee with us but
would you be stranded with us oh
definitely I could bring it forward to
work I'm ready to try shower now I'm
saying
[Applause]